Nicko special chair Chronos the broken
computer we suspect it's a motherboard
issue previously I had tried the helmet
technique because I'd actually tried
doing the clap method before which is a
sound sinking point and it didn't work
but I think I might have done something
wrong in posts I'm training again
thought about maybe like you know the
classic dial-up modems was like another
thing you do is you take the whole thing
and twist it in a circle and I'll sink
like that I'm gonna do another test
outside we will get there someday
and by someday I mean day after tomorrow
because that's when we have to film I
base my passwords on how rad it is to
type thing you don't do like the undraw
picture lighting up your desktop bro
there's so much stuff in here I'm gonna
open this leg up in this one just
wingsuit JX coded way trip to baby oh
yeah there you guys what it's all for
this is the vape blast 2014 cloud
competition finals kind of like the X
Games or what skateboarding was 20 years
ago
oh are you sponsored bro
all the weight so as you can see we have
the 360 rigged up here now so I'm going
to experiment getting a shot from up
here right here you see that so
basically this clip that should go here
is actually right here you see how this
is really smooth and this is all brick
one of the walls has like very low
detail and it took that entire clip that
should go here and protect it on the
other side and I don't actually know how
to manually change that connected to
this turn them on all at the same time
record all at the same time they're not
all the same camera so we're getting
weird issues cuz they highly recommend
using the exact same camera let's do it
we're going little tokes gonna do a test
shot see if this thing really works is a
kid I love this style I want to slide
that his body like I'm on a double dare
physical challenge wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute wait
wait wait but wait a minute